welcome to philanthropy and action where
we uncover the wonderful stories of
people to give their time talent and
treasure to change the world these are
stories of philanthropy I'm thrilled to
welcome Ellen Gibson McGinnis here today
to talk with us about all that she is
doing I'm also thrilled to have our Yale
students who will be participating in
the conversation please introduce
yourselves my name is Daniel my name is
Christina my name is mcclain my name is
Stephen and I'm Claire thank you all for
being here today Ellen you are a
corporate lawyer you focus on foreign
and domestic banks and yet given your
busy life with your family you're a
mother of two children you find the time
to give so much to Yale you were the
chair of the board of governors and now
you serve as chairman emeritus and you
also chair yell women how do you do it
and why do you do that I can't answer
how I do it it's a deep dark secret I
can talk a little bit about that I am I
am compelled to do it when people ask me
why I volunteer for you my historic
answer is that somebody asked me
somebody asked me a long time ago to
participate in one yell activity and
that led me to participate in yet
another and another and I found that as
I went through it the more I engaged
with other yelled volunteers the more I
wanted to do it it's it's hard to
explain actually you know I asked Julian
Bond a similar question how did he
become involved in activism and he said
because someone asked me yeah it's so
important to ask and so now I'm going to
ask Daniel sure so what specifically
grabs you about alumni issues and if you
dream big what do you what do you see
for the aya and five years or 50 years
hmm boy the aya has come a long way in
the last five years and that's a really
printing question because we are
actually
looking to see what we're what we're
going to be like five years from now
what grabs me about alumni issues I
don't think it's any one issue I think
it's how you engage alumni to serve Yale
serve each other and serve the world
that's really what the a way is focused
on and that means that we try to engage
alumni in the way that they are happiest
connecting or they feel passionate about
connecting and I see specific
programming that we'd be thinking about
in the next five years but I think what
we want to do is first of all inform the
Alumni population that that's really
what we're all about now and try to
bring more of them into the the fold to
do just that but I see really sort of
anchoring our gains as far as that
that's a change from how the AI used to
be so anchoring our gains around that
bringing more people into the fold and
and then you know there's some specific
programming which is probably not what
you're asking wanted so what do you sort
of understand it's like the really
really big picture you know 50 years
from now you know what does the a way I
look like what can you tell us that's a
really good question I think 50 years
from now I think Yale students will
understand what the aya what their
alumni life might look like when they're
freshmen as soon as they walk in the
door they'll see the they'll see the
connection was Yale as a lifelong thing
and that's really what we're trying to
do with the anyway I think that's going
to take a lot of time but that's really
the goal to see yourself from the
beginning as someone who has this
relationship with other Yale ease and
with the university that helps inform
how you act in the world for a lifetime
I want you to explain why you think
that's important well I think yell is a
place that and I think this may be
partly self-selection yells a place that
tends to when they say they're guilty
actually states that it wants to Train
global leaders okay and we're not just
talking about people to lead
corporations or law firms and I think
he'll actually attracts a person who's
interested in being a leader in every
aspect of his or her life and and giving
back
is a really big part of that it's
incredible to me when I talk to other
alums and we talk about what we've done
it the a way recently to do go beyond
your you know what class are you in or
what region do you live in people are so
attracted to that idea because they do
they it resonates with them it resonates
with yell ease the notion of giving back
and giving back in in lots of different
ways and I wasn't intentional about that
I wouldn't have been able to answer this
question in the same way when I started
when someone just asked me I did it
because I thought well it'll be fun to
hang out with the alleys but now now I
see that that's really common thread
that people respond to and act on well I
know McClain is dying to get in on this
conversation yeah i'm really i'm
actually really interested in in your
philanthropy with yale and how you've
worked with the aya cuz i'm just
recently working with aya as well for
the reunions at the end of semester so
i'm really interested in that
organization but i want to ask you a
little bit about your involvement with
yale women and I'm actually involved in
several women's organizations here on
campus and you know one is a great
organization and another one is the
Women's Leadership Conference and
women's leadership here at Yale I was
wondering I don't know a lot about Yale
women and i would i'd really like to
find out more about that so what kinds
of philanthropic efforts has has has
have you been involved with with VL
women well yo M is very new we just
launched it in december so we don't have
any specific philanthropic efforts that
have come out of the organization but
yeah women i see as it's almost like a
mini aya when you think about their
50,000 VL women alums and across the
world and from graduate the graduate
school freshman school graduate school
professional schools and the college and
we have a strategic plan which you can
beam which talks about this piece that
you're talking about philanthropy giving
back one of our pillars is contribution
two of them are actually contributions
to society and contributions to Yale and
I find that the women this is this group
has come out of a number of years of
people feeling like we needed to have a
women's group because in a way it's the
same thing I talked about before when I
get together with other young women its
interest
ding and stimulating and exciting and we
just love conversing with each other no
matter what class we're in what you know
in terms of age group or society or
profession so in a way it seems
self-serving you know it's what do we
get out of this we get out of this real
enjoyment of being together but the same
common themes seem to arise in terms of
what people want to do they want to get
back we want to mentor Yale students we
want to mentor other alums we're
interested in lifelong learning we do
want to develop ways to be philanthropic
ourselves to partner with other
nonprofit organizations to to give back
to our communities so building community
that's another one of our pillars
actually so so it's very exciting we're
very much in the startup phase of it but
and what year did you say you were I'm a
sophomore okay so you're already a
member because if you've been in a
degree program at Yale for one semester
you're considered in a loan all alums
and you're already member feeling I was
going to ask you ask you as well how do
you integrate the younger population of
Yale of Yale women and how can how can
my my friends and I get involved well we
have a committee on campus partnerships
we're already looking to look to the
students and to and other campus
organizations actually probably some
other people you work with any
organizations are aware of us and
started working with us but you know
it's the same it's part of what my
answer before what we'd like to do is
make people aware that we exist do some
work while we're while you're on campus
maybe when you're home for spring
breaker in the summertime get involved
with whatever's in your region and you
know part of it is an awareness that
when you come out if when you come out
after senior year if you're already
aware of all the alumni opportunities
we're much more likely to get you
involved which is you know it really the
answer your question I think that that's
that's really great I just the last
point is that we we spoke with Donna
Dubinsky last week and she's also in
alamo VL and in branford college I
believe and she was saying that she I
was asking her why she decided to donate
to you and why this important to her and
she said that you know it's important
because she almost 0 something back to
you because they supported her and she
was you know gained a lot and she is
where she is today because of you know
so i think that's interesting and
empowering Yale women in order to
to give back to you and also build up
the experiences of opportunities for
young women today I mean I think I think
that is part of the core of how we feel
is that we were privileged to be here
and we owe Society for that privilege
and and that's part of where the impetus
for giving that comes from Christina hey
thank you so much for coming today when
I find really fascinating about your
philanthropy is that you give to
encourage other people also to give back
to Yale and we've talked in the series
with philanthropists who give to build
schools or to de nom foment like civil
rights movements but you're giving is
different in that special way so what
are some methods that you've used to try
to have people to give back to Yale and
where are some difficulties you've
encountered in that well let me parse it
a little bit because we one of the
things that I think about when I was
first asked to participate was this is a
way I can give back because at the time
I didn't have a lot of money but I can
give my time and talent to help that
time it was a local Yale Club so I think
that in a way it's easy for me to get
people to it's easier to give you ask
people to give time and talent than
money I find it easier and it's usually
usually get a response so what we'll do
with the with you women as an example or
even the aya is to try to get people
involved as I was talking about before
was something that they're passionate
about say this is an opportunity for you
to a come back and meet other Ellie's to
get engaged in that way to get
intellectual stimulation when you come
back to campus to revisit your college
experience I mean that's sort of a hook
that seems very selfish but in the
process you come involved in an
organization that actually leads to some
of the other things that you're talking
about and what you know things that are
happening in the alumni world through
support of the aya and I hope will
happen with Yale women are building
schools helping you know in education in
the arts and you know you
name it that somebody's interested in
doing we we can help generate those
activities through bringing Ellie's
together I think the biggest challenge
is really getting the word out about it
is making people understand there's a
there's some famous stories about we're
going to the details but when alums get
communication from Yale most of them
assume they're being asked for money and
we don't ask for my we asked for time
and talent we asked for ideas I think
the hardest challenge is to get the
Alumni world to understand that that's
what we're there for is to create
relationships and to to help connect
them back to the University right so on
the topic of creating these
relationships what are some examples of
successful programming that help to
maintain these communities outside of
you for people who may have been in
different class years they've never met
before how does that factor into
maintaining and gluing these communities
together well the one that comes to mind
quickest is the Yale Service Corps one
of our initiatives in the last five
years was to have this yell Service
Corps which now has its own through sub
board of the aya who started out with a
project going to the Dominican Republic
over spring break four years ago maybe
to partner with an organization down
there to work in in the community and
what's fascinating about that is there
was an email sent out from Yale to ask
people to go on the trip it had the word
service in the subject line and I cannot
tell you how many people I think about a
hundred people went on the trip but a
huge percentage of them had never done
anything in connection with UL before
and some of these were people who
graduated in the 60s and they work they
said they only open to email because
they saw the word service and they
thought it was such a great idea to go
with other Yale ease and some of them
some of them took families the Dominican
Republic to do with a service project
that they joined up and they have since
a lot of them have sent to become very
very involved and we've had many many
trips since then but I think again it's
broadening the way you think about how
alumni interact with each other and the
world there are a lot of universities
who don't get this they say well why
would I want to partner with Habitat for
Humanity and bring my XYZ college
to do that what do I get out of it and
our question is not what do I get out of
it it's it's um what can i bring to it
and and it's a hard question I mean is
there such a thing as altruism you know
it you know i get i get a lot out of
this i almost feel guilty because I I do
this because I enjoy it so much and I
get to meet fabulous people like maximan
and interact with students but I think
there's something something beyond that
that just but you you try to we've
appealed to that and brought into the
aya fold actively people who didn't have
time for it before didn't think they
cared put you on the spot when a lot of
the world here is Yale they think
privilege they think elite they think it
has so much more resources visa V any
other entity why invest in this well
it's an interesting question and I think
that it I'm going to answer it with my
actual fundraising hat on because I also
do some fundraising for you as a member
of the class of 82 what I tell people
when I have to go out as a class agent
and ask them to give is yell is doing a
tremendous amount in the world that I
don't think people realize it's not just
the impact of students like you look off
in the world to do amazing things it's
incredible what the students of today
are doing in their own community and
globally it's not just what you will do
with your intellect when you go on to
your job in whatever sector you you have
it in the future it's it's not just the
knowledge that comes out of New Haven
they're doing projects all over the
world there's scientific projects you
know finding that fern in Africa that's
going to be the next wonder drug you
know we're doing nursing projects in
China we're teaching helping to teach
the Chinese universities about a liberal
arts education which is going to have
ripple effects for education of people
in that part of the world there is so
much that Yale is doing and yell is a
rich institue
but it's what it's doing with that is
it's being a not just a thought leader
but having an actual impact in the world
that I don't think people really think
about and I think that's worth
supporting beyond its and again people
say well you know I'm just supporting
kids to come to school in New Haven it's
only 5,000 of them are you know 10,000
if you count the graduate school that's
not what it's about is it's got it's a
catalyst for a lot of other really
important things in the world I think
Stephen so you mentioned impact and I
find that attempting to maximize impact
is a large draw for me and trying to
decide what to do with my present or
future time talent and treasure do you
think that such photometric is
appropriate in some all or no
circumstances I think it's right I think
it's hard to measure sometimes but I
think it's very appropriate you know
when you talk about how do you measure
the impact of dollars it's it's somewhat
easier to do you know if I if is a
fundraiser to x y&z I will get you know
a B and C dollars when you try to
measure the impact of human capital
which is what we're talking about it's
difficult but I think it's really
important partly because if we think
that the donation of time and talent is
important then it would be good to be
able to measure it to show the impact
it's something we struggle with metrics
is something we struggle with at the AOA
because we think what we do is important
and we know that it leads to stronger
connections and many times to giving you
gauge somebody more in any kind of
organization but with Yale and they see
part of what I was just talking about or
they see how what a fabulous place it is
just locally on campus and what kind of
opportunity it's providing for people
who will go out and make an impact in
the world they are more likely to give
and that's important too but I think
it's a really good question but it's
hard to figure out how to do it okay so
even human capital aside dollar for
dollar do you think donations to Yale
can compare an impact to donations say
to
that's covering children in Africa who
are dying from malaria yes I do I think
that you know personally I choose a
couple of select causes that I give my
money to be on dl I do give TL
financially and it's probably important
to support if there's something that
you're very interested in that you see
and that's a great example of something
that's got a low cost and a high impact
itself and I think that's important but
what I would say about Yale is Yale can
often it's almost like basic research of
course which goes on here you know I'm
very interested in maintaining financing
for basic research beyond what will it
do for me in a way it's I don't care
what the impact is right because most of
what we've learned in medicine over the
last hundred years has come from people
doing basic creatures where they had no
idea where I was going so I would say
that that's Yale I think that Yale is
doing specific projects you can point to
I really like that they're doing that
that they're educating the Chinese
educators but on the other hand I think
they're also doing things that are
inspiring thought they are also doing
basic research not just in the sciences
but in other areas and it's important to
support this kind of institution and I
support this one because it's where I
went does that answer the question in
the bedroom clear um so thus far we've
talked about two different ways that
you've persuaded alumni to give back in
their time in committing to service and
also in their treasure and donating to
Yale I wonder is there a difference in
the way that you ask for those two
different kinds of philanthropy do you
change the way that you approach the
issue change the way that you send out
contact information does it vary at all
it does and I have to say I think I'm
really bad at fundraising it's not
something I like to do I signed up to be
a class agent because I'm married to a
classmate and someone came to me and
said okay we've got about 12 couples who
are married to each other our class
would you be the people who go out and
ask them for money so I'm actually
asking people in a similarly situated
and some of whom I know I'm very
profound about it I don't do a good job
so but I when I do engage in the
conversation I have the conversation I
talked about before I something
bilar much better at that and I am
passionate about the cause and actually
as I've been more involved with you it's
much easier for me to ask for money
because I can talk about the things I
just talked about I can talk about the
reasons why I think it's important that
have impact but it's it's much different
it's so easy to ask someone you know the
person who asked me just call me episode
you know you've been in i lived in
towson time you've been in dallas for a
year we've got this Yale Club we need
somebody to do the Vice President of
Programming will you do it you know and
it's say oh that's first of all that
makes you feel good right will you do
this job I'll give you a title and it's
easy to ask people I think to do
something something with time and talent
especially because you can also frame it
and say all I need is you you know this
many hours on this one project or I need
you to commit to get on a path to do
what I've done and spend 14 years you
know engaged in a real way but I think
and you have the commonality of yellow
of course with with the ladder even more
easily than than for money it's easy to
say hey you know we already have this
connection that's why I'm talking to you
in the first place people tend to people
tend to want to be involved they can see
what it's going to look like no so I
think it's very different so actually
related to commonality I read the
article that you publish in the Yale
alumni magazine the call for service
right and one of the things that you
suggested was that individual or alumni
should donate two groups that they were
associated with while they were on
campus either the political union or
yell women groups that they identify
with what role do you think that
identity plays in asking alums to give
back either in time or in treasure well
I think that's what we've discovered is
very important because it used to be
that the aya we had classes and clubs
regional clubs and then graduate
professional school affiliation and
frankly we were much more focused on the
classes and clubs it was a much more
college Yale College oriented
organization and there were people who
loved that I was very involved with my
class and I love my classmates and I
come back to reunions and that's great I
got involved in a regional club because
somebody asked me to but we were leaving
out a lot of people we were leaving out
people
who didn't feel as though that they fit
in because of their actual identity
their you know their racial identity or
their religious identity or something
that was more definable about them that
you can maybe see or understand when you
interacted with them and people who
wanted to connect because they were in a
singing group where they were with the
pillow of the Union I think part of what
we're doing is instead of imposing a way
to connect on people saying how do you
want to connect how do you want to be
involved what was what were you
passionate about passionate about when
you are here at Yale we can find it you
know would you be interested in helping
us find a way for you to connect back
through that passion and it's been very
successful we have this [ __ ] what we
call the shared interest groups which
reflect both the sort of interest and
identity that people have and there's
there's over a hundred of them it's it's
really it's almost more than we can
handle because people responded so to
that so I think that that makes the
difference on that when you bring first
your time and talent and now your
Treasury to this institution until the
other organizations that you support are
you also bringing a vision of what you
would like Yale to do or what you would
like the role to be for this catalyst if
Lily's a catalyst in the world or are
you more of a passive investor in
whatever it is the organization is doing
well I actually think that when I give
money it's probably the latter that I
fine I got tired of giving ten dollars
here and there every time somebody asked
me for something so I decided to really
direct it and I looked for things that I
thought looked for organizations i
thought we're doing a really great job
that's something that I cared about and
because I think they're doing a really
great job I will give them my money and
you know let them do whatever they need
to do with it and that that includes
Yale in terms of my yell giving actually
occasionally I'll direct it within the
university I used to always in fact I
still do direct my sort of annual you
know sort of basic level of giving to
finance
you can do that when you give your
that's one of the boxes you can check
and then for my reunion gift I gave it
to the the new library you know so there
were specific things that I thought
that's great I want to support that
thing but I think in terms of the time
again there is this sort of you know
loop that gets created of feed you know
positive feedback to me and then we
keeping engaged with it and because of
the role that I've had being on the
board as you know and then being the
chair I've had a lot of ability to
direct what we do at the aya so you know
i'm not sure what my vision is for the
future but i think i was able to help
get to where we are now through having a
vision when I started out partly was
seeing deficits but apart Leigh it was
being able to visualize the you know
what we could become and it's a lot
about this connection and that we really
could get people to engage if we let
them tell us how right
okay was I you've um you've mentioned
already that um this is this is fun for
you this feels good this is it's
compelling you can't stop so I guess do
you think is that one philanthropy is at
its most effective is when it's not even
some sort of sacrifice it's sort of this
idea of enlightened self-interest you
you want to give is that when it's at
its best absolutely I absolutely do and
I think that's the interesting about the
the time talent vs vs fundraising that I
am I don't I expect you could
potentially have that feeling if you
gave enough money or to the right thing
and have the right effect but it's very
clear to me that everybody that I work
with as a Yale volunteer at the LA young
women in other places has that you know
enlightened self-interest positive
feedback loop going on which makes it
easy to keep doing it yeah one of the
things that we are discovering about
people who are active in philanthropy is
how that philanthropy turns on
interesting things like gender like
region like religious background were
you did you ever attend religious school
I did not but I grew up in a very
religious you know Catholic family with
very devout parents not extreme in any
way but very you know very steadily
devout went to church every Sunday and
it's interesting that you mentioned that
because one of the causes I support came
out of my church experience Covenant
House so coveted do you guys know coming
in half the original founder of Covenant
House came to my church when I was 13
years old and was the guest person to
give a sermon and talked about covenant
house which is at the time was just in
New York which is a place where runaway
children could come and be taken in and
sometimes reconnect with their families
and sometimes not but taken in and cared
for and closed and now they do job
training and all kinds of things
and they're in many cities and I was 13
years old this made such an impression I
mean I started giving money when I was
13 to this cause and that is one of the
ones that I have kept as a defined cause
that I you know I try to support in some
significant way so I don't know how that
ties in I mean obviously there was a
there was a religious component to that
there was a you know a feeling of
helping people less fortunate than
myself and understanding that that was
part of what I was supposed to do but it
was even now I can almost remember the
sort of emotional connection that made
me say that's you know I want to do
something about that no covenant house I
use it by way of explaining how you've
stayed connected now Covenant House has
had a rocky road for a little bit yes as
Yale has had an any any organization
goes through how did you and why did you
stay with them or stay with Yale or any
through the hard times why do you do
that well because I think in that
particular instance the the mission of
the organization and the work of the
organization was clear the mission was
clear and important and the work of the
organization was going to go on in spite
of the difficulties that they had with
the leadership they were going to get
the right new leaders and they did in
fact at the right new leaders to
continue this mission I suppose if i
were there in the inside the walls of
that organization at the time i might
have wondered whether it was going to
survive but as an outsider i thought
it's almost more important for me to
continue to support them because they
probably will have less support because
of the you know the things that go on
and and with with yale as well with yale
i actually don't see I haven't been so
involved in a time when I thought there
was a problem you know there have been
lots of issues that have come out it you
know publicly about things that Yale
gets criticized for but I've been in a
way on the inside you know I know the
administration and I can see what's
going on and how they react as people to
some of the things that go on and I see
the good faith and what I feel is a real
commitment to the right values so
probably part of the effect of my being
able to be involved at this level and
give this time in talent is that I also
am able to see the
it's almost like politics right you see
that you can spend enough time to figure
out what's really going on and examine
the nuances and not react to a
superficiality about a situation but I
so I think it's important really in both
cases focusing on what's really
happening and what the mission is and
what you want to help them accomplish
that's make sense it does thanks a lot
of things so well and I have I have a
couple more questions for you but first
I just wanted to ask you did mention the
Covenant House and also Yale that you
films are probably give to but what
other organizations do you support oh
gosh putting me on the spot I support
well I support my children's educational
institutions because they're both
actually in a private educational
institution I support I'm drawing a
blank there is one other that I give
significant money to every year and I
forgot what it is okay well I can I can
but it started I mean it's really in
what I consider to be a significant
amount of money to you know three or
four organizations and I still will
support you know friends who were doing
the polar bear plunge you know to raise
support for their favorite thing
occasionally so it's not like I don't
give any money to anything else but I
really feel like it's better to have a
bigger impact and in a place by getting
more to do all I think that's really
interesting because you know as a class
we're dealing with you know who which
organization are we going to support and
I think it's really interesting that you
support the Covenant House it has you
know has had its ups and downs and also
of Yale which is a huge organization
that receives a lot of money each year
so and I know Stephen touched on this a
little bit but what if I still have for
us as a class that is you know looking
into huge organizations but also looking
locally into small organizations like
the Columbus house that is you know that
then you know not the Covenant House but
it's around its around New Haven and
it's a smaller organization but we're
also looking at against malaria
foundation which is in Africa that is is
a huge organization that supports a lot
of a lot of children so what what if I
see you press yeah I mean it's hard to
make those decisions well I think it
useful to think about you know what your
mission is you know I think for me I
decided that I would pick a couple of
things that I wanted to promote they're
mostly in the education related area
although Covenant houses and exactly in
that and you know I I don't know I think
it's a really hard question because you
have to decide are you going to are you
going to support something that has a
broad reach and a broad impact but maybe
not as as high an impact necessarily are
you going to support something that has
a real focus and is in your own
community you know this is it this is a
real debate do you support something
across the ocean do you suppose
something next door we have this to pay
for Yale surface did we do all of our
trips abroad or should we start doing
trips in the US there's so much to be
done you know the better question might
be can you develop some kind of
philosophy your mission that you can
stick to you know that's that's really
and you're in a sort of unique situation
you're not an organization that's going
to go on for a long time with this so i
think i think it is very difficult but I
do actually think that I don't know if
you have the option of you know giving a
lot of little bit of money to a lot of
different things I do think that a lot
of money to a small one or two
organizations is probably has more of an
impact thank you sure well Ellen thank
you so much for sharing your insights
and your time and talent you're laughing
I'm so happy to do it with our students
and thank you students for those really
searing questions of our guest Ellen
Gibson McGinnis the chairman emeritus of
the Yale Board of Governors it has been
wonderful doing today's program on
philanthropy and action l insured with
us how important is to be passionate in
supporting organizations that are making
a difference and I ask you what are you
doing to change the world